something seems to really have
Republicans in a highly triggering state
lately
last week or maybe it was the week
before they stormed into an impeachment
related meeting claiming that they
wanted access to impeachment stuff that
was happening secretly in the basement
of some building with only Democrats of
course we later found out that many of
the same Republicans that stormed in
demanding access have access to
impeachment documents and two witnesses
since many of those Republicans are on
the committee's that are involved in the
impeachment inquiry yesterday instead of
storming in they stormed out doesn't
matter though they just want to be
storming around this time storming out
of a Veterans Affairs Committee meeting
refusing to vote on a health care bill
for women veterans what is wrong with
this people with these people this is
how it went the House Veterans Affairs
Committee was meeting about a bill for
women veterans health care to get them
health care Republicans did what they
often do and sometimes Democrats do this
too they suggest a variety of amendments
which Democrats rightly identified as
poison pill amendments California
Democrat mark Takano
stopped the debate on these proposed
amendments because as he says these are
toxic partisan amendments they wouldn't
actually improve health care for women
veterans which was the point of the
discussion that we're having about this
bill the Republicans became irate how
dare you accuse us of that and then a
whole bunch of them stormed out and it
was filmed take a look
now it's true the amendments they were
proposing had no place in this
discussion whatsoever to bill about
women veterans health care they were
proposing amendments related to veterans
firearms rights for child care these are
fine things to discuss and debate and to
legislate but this is a bill about women
veterans health care and this is a
really common thing in American politics
amendments that are unrelated are
introduced
sometimes the point is to get things
passed as amendments that you couldn't
possibly get passed the standalone bills
that's one reason for these crazy
amendments the other reason sometimes
crazy amendments are proposed is to
prevent the bill in total from passing
by suggesting crazy and unrelated things
the good news here is that the bill
called the Deborah Sampson Act was
passed by the committee even without
Republicans voting on it they had the
votes and now it will go to a full vote
in the house I don't really believe in
stuff like karma but if there are just
desserts in our world
Republicans would deserve to be kicked
out of office in 2020 by the people that
they have so endlessly screwed over I'm
talking about veterans I'm talking about
farmers I mean in a sense I'm talking
about most groups in general no matter
how you slice or dice it now that I
think about it
but this is another example of
Republicans love the military when it's
useful and politically advantageous if
it's about supporting some harebrained
intervention in some part of the world
let's support the troops and not say
that the mission they're on is not a
good one and then when it's not so
useful when it comes to providing them
health care when it comes to former
members of the military who might have
something to say that's negative about
Donald Trump like lieutenant colonel
Alexander VIN Minh all of a sudden all
of that Pro military stuff evaporates
very very quickly this has come up so
many times recently on the show because
recently it's been particularly
prevalent and extraordinarily braised
and they don't really care about the
troops in the real way that they should
making sure that they are properly cared
for when they come back
from engagements abroad all of the other
things that we've been talking about
this is yet another one of those
instances vote on the bill get the women
veterans health care now we need
amendments about gun ownership give me a
break make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show and follow me on instagram
at david pakman